donc à ce plan l'essentiel il manque les
moyens il ya pas de moyens
supplémentaires
et puis y'a pas le sens de l'urgence moi
je serais pour la création immédiate de
milliers de milliers d'appartements de
refuse parce que je pas d'accord avec
karim parce que dans le système de karim
l'homme qui est évacuée il sait encore
où se trouve sa victime moi je trouve
que l'urgence est de soustraire
immédiatement c'est la femme à un homme
il ya deux mesures d'hygiène mesure
d'interdiction d'approcher la hilaire
espagne car ils la respectent pas la loi
de la tôle si tu la respectes pas là où
il faut s'accroît ainsi tu caches la
nicolière l'homme ne s'est pas tu règle
le problème une bonne fois pour toutes
si elle reste chez elle dans la loi
actuelle c'est ce qu'on voit
il ya des mesures d'éloignement qui ne
sont jamais respectées l'homme 80 ans
éric liberge de nos enfants eric gillard
trouvera les souvent la maman refuse de
quitter le domicile parce que on va les
assure perdent leurs repères qu'est ce
qu'on fait et enfants valides en dessin
mais il va falloir trancher entre les
deux feux que lever une commune autre
hacker eric ce n'est pas possible ou
quoi c'est lui qui doit être traqués ces
deux annonces réversion par exemple en
étant moi je suis plus favorable
or il ya très très peu de logements qui
ont été créés dans les plans donc jeudi
une première fois non sur le plan
théorique et jeudi une deuxième fois non
sur le plan pratique il ya une dame qui
m'a contactée sur un réseau social
on a commencé à discuter elle a eu des
problèmes de graves problèmes avec son
mari elle a commencé à me dire qu'elle a
changé cette fois d'adressent mais qu'il
a retrouvé des supras il m'a montré les
taxes sur la voiture et surtout elle m'a
montré son visage après que cet homme
l'a massacrée et je lui dis qu'est ce
que vous pensez de du débat du grenelle
elle me dit ça ne changera rien il n'y a
pas d'issue ou plutôt il n'y en a qu'une
c'est la mort donc si une intéressez
vous dit après avoir vu tout ça je pense
que le gouvernement passe à côté de
l'essentiel on peut saluer les efforts
qui ont été fournis mais je crains que
pour beaucoup de victimes en soi très
très loin du compte
les styles ce cas précis si elle va
porter plainte et qu'on s'occupe d'eux
donné la portée plus de ceux de ce
fumier spéciaux il faut ça l'occupé moi
je ne parle pas je ne s'occupe pas des
ddc dellinger abc chocolat ne sont pas
là c'est là où il ya un problème dans le
dispositif du gouvernement c'est que on
a beaucoup parlé de la parole donc
libérer la parole et ça on le doit
aujourd'hui ou mouvements planétaires
mis tous y aller coûte
et c'est vrai qu'il ya des programmes
de formation des gendarmes des policiers
des professeurs et que c'était des juges
bon ok ça ces écoutes
mais une fois même des élus dans les
permanences d'élus on va le faire
quelques heures de formation aux élus
qui pour recevoir les femmes
une fois que tu a recueilli cette parole
si quand tu appelles les dispositifs de
logements d'hébergement d'action il ya
pas parce que les associations sont sous
dotées parce qu'il ya physiquement pas
les moyens pour répondre du coup à tout
ce qui est parole et écoute est abolie
dans une quelque chose qui ait abouti à
une connaissance certaine de son propre
danger et il dans l'indifférence
générale c'est ça le problème les
associations avaient chiffré à un
milliard le budget nécessaire et le
gouvernement moi je que je trouve assez
indécent c'est que il communique sur un
an le chiffre malin de chapa jeu on dire
je doute pas de ses bonnes intentions
mais je trouve je trouve pas correct
qu'elle communique sur le chiffre de
1,16 milliard comme elle le fait depuis
48 heures qui est un chiffre faut c'est
incroyable d'ailleurs vous savez alors
là je vais faire un petit peu de
finances publiques mais dans les
finances publiques vous savez y aller il
ya les ja les autorisations d'engagement
donc là ce sont des sommes que l'état
dit on a le droit de les dépenser puis
après il ya un autre chose qu'ils savent
les crédits de paiement et ça c'est le
vrai l'oseille les crédits de paiement
eh ben ce milliard dont parle marlène
schiappa ce sont des autorisations
d'engagement pas des crédits de paiement
et le sénat il a fermé un rapport en
disant qu'ils n'avaient que la moitié
qui était du crédit de paiement est pire
que ça en fait dans le programme que
présente marlène schiappa il dit c'est
tout ça ça valait dans la lutte pour
l'égalité femmes hommes et en fait on
s'aperçoit que 75% de ce milliard il va
sur l'aide au développement et la
coopération internationale parce qu'en
fait ils ont considéré que toutes les
actions du gouvernement qui allaient
dans le centre de l'égalité homme femme
ait été à mettre dans le milliard donc
en fait là je trouve quelque chose
d'assez indécence à dire que ce qui
avait été demandé c'est voilà de
l'argent des moyens et au lieu de ça on
a une communication qui donc chacun
c'est parce qu'on a tous conscience
qu'elle aboutit à plus de morts et c'est
vrai je suis comme dj kaïo riche vie
comme il peut et le gouvernement il faut
qu'il faut que ça marche mais pour ceux
qui en suivent il eût fallu qu'on fasse
comme pour les gilet jaune
l'année dernière un collectif budgétaire
l'an décembre pour rajouter au budget
les sommes nécessaires et pour l'instant
ils ne veulent pas le faire
donc moi je remercie les associations
qui ont organisé la manif du 23 novembre
franchement moi j'y étais et il faut
obliger c'est extraordinaire parce qu'il
y avait une telle intention de la night
bleus étaient venus on avait bien fait
pas 500 démission qui avait en avance
annoncé la manif du 23 me veulent je
trouve qu'on avait bien fait de le faire
et merci merci merci à nous tout merci à
vous les familles de victimes qui
avaient fait ça mais maintenant il faut
que tout ça maintenant ça aboutisse quoi